the day started out actually at an MSNBC
live taping that's taking place a couple
blocks away from the Trump rally and I
kind of went there first cuz I was very
nervous about going to the Trump rally
and I went there first because it was
more of a comfort zone and just started
chatting with people and everyone I told
I was like I'm thinking about going over
the rally and they were like don't do it
they're horrible people they're the
lowest of the low they're going to
harass you
one woman actually offered me her pepper
spray to take with me and I was like no
I think I'm gonna be fine it'll be okay
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report quick reminder everybody you can
get all our shows days early and totally
ad-free at Rubin report comm and joining
me today is a psychologist and author
and a contributor to Forbes magazine dr.
Carlin borisenko welcome to the Rubin
report thanks for having me Dave I am
glad to have you here unfortunately due
to social distancing we are not doing
this in person you are all the way in
New Hampshire so we are roughly 3,000
miles apart as I told you right before
we started we're gonna be holding this
interview for just a little bit because
there's so many moving pieces in the
world right now but how is lockdown
treating you
lockdowns treating me quite well
honestly I work out of my house it's not
really about different the only
difference is that my husband is now
working from home and so we'll see if
our marriage survives this but he's a
good guy so I think we're gonna be just
fine yeah and you just told me that he
took the dogs outside at least while
you're doing this so you know he's
making himself useful that's nice
he does you know that's why you keep
them around right Yeah right
I assume so all right so a couple months
ago you really got put on the map with a
piece that you wrote that obviously
we're gonna spend a lot of this
interview talking about but before we
get to that you're a psychologist first
tell me a little bit about your
background the types of things you're
interested in and then we'll get that to
what sort of brought you to my attention
yeah so I'm actually an organizational
psychologist so I focused mostly on
helping to create positive working
environment
the bulk of my academic research has
been in the area of workplace bullying
which played into what we're going to
talk about quite a bit so I've studied
it quite extensively I help
organizations tackle those types of
challenges and just to make work better
for people so they don't have to stress
out all the time yeah which probably is
coming in very handy these days as
everybody's kind of working from home
and figuring out new ways they have to
do things and all that right yeah
absolutely and I actually think this is
going to fundamentally change the
relationships that a lot of
organizations have with flexible work so
in some respects it's actually going to
be very exciting for people once I think
things get back to normal yeah do you
sense that we'll get to a whole new way
of looking at I think not only just
looking at the world as a general idea
but we're looking at work that people
are gonna realize they can telecommute
and work from home and maybe spend more
time with their spouses and maybe don't
want to be on the road two hours a day
getting to work and commuting and the
rest of it well I think it's going to
have to because so many organizations
and now have staffs that are completely
work at home and a lot of them kind of
went there kicking and screaming they
got pushed off the cliff now their staff
is seeing well we can make this work and
we don't necessarily always need to be
in the office and so it's going to have
to change the relationship I think it's
it's really funny I'm actually working
with a group of managers right now who
are transitioning their teams to working
virtually they almost have to go back to
basics and it's they just they they have
to like build their workspaces and teach
their teams how to how to tune in these
virtual environments but once they get
there they're going to be okay
yeah you think most people actually are
better left to their own devices or do
you think because we're social creatures
we a lot of us need to actually show up
somewhere and you've done different
clothes and you know behave differently
with other co-workers and things like
that yeah I think it's it's a little bit
of both to be honest we still need those
social interactions but also one of the
keys to working at home well is to have
a routine to get up to take a shower not
sit around in your PJs all day have a
dedicated workspace and so that's and
that's part of what's gonna help people
maintain work/life balance and really be
able to focus their energy on the things
that matter and so I think you know
people people are figuring it out and
from home is weird I mean you know this
it's like sometimes you you forget to
eat sometimes you forget what time it is
you forget to stop working at five
o'clock and so people are having to
tackle that as well yeah when I was
writing my book I would go into our
green room here which is a bedroom and I
would just start at about 7:30 or 8:00
a.m. and I'd be writing writing writing
and then it would literally be 2 p.m.
and David would basically slide a plate
of food through the door he would open
up the door slide it in not even bother
me because I would legitimately forget
to eat because I was so just in that
zone oh the same when I my book I was up
here 1 2 a.m. in the morning and I would
go downstairs my husband be like what
the heck happened to you where did you
go and it's just the way it is when you
get into that flow of work yeah all
right so you're a psychologist and
you're doing some interesting stuff that
obviously is very relevant as we're
talking about - - the way we're all
living right now but what sort of put
you on the map here was this piece that
you wrote that all started well you were
part of a knitting community and we can
all imagine how radical the knitting
communities are tell me a little bit
about the Knitting communities online
I'm not in the knitting world I don't
know what's going on over there I have
respect for the knitters but tell me
about the knitting community Oh Dave
prepare to have your mind blown what's
going on this all started about a year
ago and in the Knitting community I'm
talking about this is not a knitting
circle of little old ladies this is
mostly people of all different ages
Instagram kind of sharing their projects
and sharing their yarns and all these
things well about a year ago these
roving games of social justice warriors
started infiltrating different parts of
the knitting community and really
started going after and bullying and
mopping people very severely so it
started with a woman named Karen Templar
who wrote a blog post about her upcoming
trip to India and she was so excited
about going on this trip and it just she
thought it would never happened and she
was always scared to travel in all these
things and the sjw's mocked her so badly
because they said your other Emmure
you're calling all this stuff how dare
you and she had to write this full
retraction and apology and point out
every single thing that was wrong with
her blog post is into several paragraphs
long
crazy so another woman Maria Tuscon was
watching that
and she does these beautiful hand dyed
yarns and all Maria did was post a video
on YouTube saying I'm not comfortable
with what's going on and I'm going to
take some time off of Instagram well
they didn't like that and they they went
after her and mocked her tried to
destroy her business destroy all her
partnerships would post horrible
pictures of her on Instagram like
Photoshop into clan uniforms and things
like that and so that was crazy but the
thing that really got my attention was
this one guy Nathan Taylor he goes by
the name sock petition on Instagram and
all he did when all of this was going on
was to post a poem on a hashtag called
diversity asking for kindness asking for
people to be nice to each other
worst of all things oh I know and and
you know anything about him - it's like
it's a gay man in the Knitting community
so he's like that a couple of minority
cars in this instance working for him
but for his efforts he was thanked by
being mobbed by hundreds and hundreds of
people to the point where he had a
nervous breakdown and went into the
hospital on suicide watch and I'm kind
of watching all this happen and like I
said my background is in workplace
bullying I've studied adults bullying
other adults extensively and I just
thought this is not what I signed up for
and these are people that I was aligned
with politically and it really if that
was my wake-up moment to say what is
going on in the world and do I want to
really be a part of this ok so there's
there's a lot there but the the sort of
bones of your story is the type of story
that I hear all the time I've had many
of my guests I've been through my own
version of it that you know you're
basically I think you can describe your
own political positions but you know you
think of yourself as sort of a good
lefty you're knitting this is sort of a
political next thing you know some
bizarre thing happens and everyone's a
racist and a bigot we're destroying
lives and all that did you have no sense
that any of this was going on within the
community or you actually use the word
infiltrated we're these outsiders that
were coming in to suddenly wreak havoc
or were these people from within the
community themselves and I ask you this
a lot of people these days are now we're
spending more and more time online one
of the things that I'm trying to do with
my new tech company local economists
create protected communities and people
are trying to figure out how can you
gate a community and make sure that all
these bad actors you know don't get in
there now I think a lot of them were
actually part of the knitting community
and all of this too was surrounding the
site Ravelry which is one of the most
popular knitting sites on the internet
and what Ravelry did I think midway
through last year is they banned all
support for Donald Trump so you were not
allowed to say anything in the forum's
about supporting him you were not
allowed to post patterns with like Trump
2020 or anything like that and that fed
into all of this as well so what would
happen is they would like coordinate on
Ravelry and then they would go forth and
bully people on Instagram I think so
what were the types of things that you
were seeing besides just oh you're evil
you're racist you're a bigot like they
were actually trying to go for people's
jobs and as you said I mean well at
least one guy had a mental breakdown
because of it but can you talk about
that because I think a lot of times
people that don't pay that much
attention to this stuff they're always
like oh well it's just some trolls on
Twitter and there's no real-world
consequences you know toughen up it's
what is happening in the knitting world
at least is these people are not just
leaving nasty comments on people's
images they're actually going after
their businesses so what they do is
first off they pick out high-profile
people to go after because you don't
want to just go after like susie-q would
like to followers you're not gonna make
an impact that way so they go after
people that are influences in the
Knitting world and then what they do is
they direct message all of the major
knitwear designers or knitting stores
and they basically say if you do not
denounce these people we are going to
come after you too and so there are very
detrimental effects on people's
businesses and this is this is what
their livelihood is and knitting
you know like spoiler alert Dave
knitting is not like a lucrative
business right and so when we're talking
about Bill you're not getting that big
knitting money no I mean though I don't
make my money from knitting but no I
mean they're they're doing what they
need to do to get by and so it really
does have a horrible impact ok so what's
interesting about this because this is
sort of a world
it's a
very niche world that a lot of people
don't understand about but politically
now you mentioned the Trump thing
already that they one of the sites said
okay no more Pro Trump stuff you can't
knit a Trump sweater or anything like
that but politically speaking this is a
pretty female dominated lefty basically
right lefty
ideologically dominated arena so were
you shocked I mean these are the people
that are supposed to be tolerant and
diverse and open and all of those things
and you considered yourself one of them
at least at the time were you shocked
and then how did that then lead to I
think what you would now consider your
political awakening yeah so it was very
shocking to me this was not what I
perceived the the good the good tolerant
liberals to be doing and you know I
frankly hadn't been paying attention to
a lot of this stuff that was going on in
the world I was busy I was living my
life and so to see how this played out
it really did make me question
everything about my belief system and
the people I had aligned myself with
yeah can you just go through a little
bit of what your political leanings were
beforehand yeah I've called myself a
liberal for like 20 years I've been a
Democrat since I was 18 years old since
I was able to register to vote and
frankly I never really saw myself
leaving the Democratic Party up until
all this started happening so then this
all happens and you did the scariest
most evil thing someone can do you went
to a Donald J Trump rally I did but we
have to back up a little bit cuz it it
didn't actually start there it started
okay so several months before the Trump
rally and I when all this was going on I
basically said you know I need to get
out of my echo chamber I need to get out
of my liberal echo chamber because I
that was the only people I was hearing
from not just liberals but progressives
and all this and I made this concerted
effort to start listening to voices that
I thought I would disagree with and my
husband who has always been a little bit
more conservative than me said Carlin
you should listen to ben shapiro you
should watch ben shapiro you'd like him
and I said no Victor I'm not watching
ben shapiro ben shapiro is satan and
then
I mean my husband's a pretty smart guy
so eventually I listen to him I waited
until he was out of the house cuz I
didn't want to give him that point but
eventually I listened and you know turns
out as you know Ben Shapiro is not Satan
he's just like a conservative guy who is
also really funny and really smart and I
just happened to disagree with him on
something and from there it was kind of
down the down the YouTube rabbit hole
where I just started listening to all
these different people and discovering
this conservatives are really not what I
thought they were it wasn't the
perception that I had and you know
living in New Hampshire I'm very lucky I
get to see all the political candidates
up close and at one point or another I
had seen every other political candidate
and I thought you know Donald Trump's
coming to town well why not this is like
my big graduation exercise yeah so
alright so you go well first off tell me
a little bit more about the those sort
of what I describe as factory settings
that you were a liberal for twenty years
did it did it have any real meaning to
you or it was just sort of like where I
think a lot of sort of somewhat
apolitical people are where it's sort of
like Oh Democrats good Republicans bad
Democrats care about poor people
Republicans care about money like you
know for the person that's not purely
political it's just sort of the stuff
that you kind of get culturally is that
basically where you were yeah I mean
kind of I I think I was very active
politically when I was younger and then
growing up I kinda and really after
Obama was elected I kind of shut it all
off I was like okay he's got it at
Democrats in office it'll be fine but
really what I didn't realize is how much
Democrats have changed since you know
between W and what we have now and that
was really the big shocker for me
because I became a Democrat because I
didn't like I didn't like people telling
me what to do I didn't like people
telling me what music I could listen to
or trying to isolate their religion or
what I could wear or all these things
and that was what and and who to love as
well and that was why I joined
originally and it didn't occur to me
that the Democratic Party had changed so
much from the thing I joined oh I have
heard this story before what what did
you think intuitively about the
Republicans so you thought they wanted
to tell you what music you could listen
to and what video games you could play
on the rest of it
I mean there are horrible evil people
that just wanted to control everything I
said and did was my perception of the
Republicans
okay so then Trump comes to New
Hampshire and there he are there so it
the day started out actually at an MSNBC
live taping that's taking place a couple
blocks away from the Trump rally and I
kind of went there first I was very
nervous about going to the Trump rally
and I went there first because it was
more of a comfort zone and just started
chatting with people and everyone I told
I was like I'm thinking about going over
the rally and they were like don't do it
they're horrible people they're the
lowest of the low they're going to
harass you one woman actually offered me
her pepper spray to take with me and I
was like no I think I'm gonna be fine
it'll be okay and so then I went over to
the rally and you know you have to get
there early because the line is really
big and long and you're just kind of
hanging out and chatting with people and
discovered there these are not bad
people there was not a Klan uniform in
sight I didn't meet a Nazi that I am
aware of there's normal everyday people
like veterans and schoolteachers and
small business owners that just had
different ideas about how the country
should run how shocked were you I mean
it sounds obvious right the way you're
saying it now it's like of course it's
obvious these are regular people they
just happen to have different political
thoughts than what is sort of more
mainstream accepted but for you as
someone that wasn't part of this bubble
you get there and you start seeing this
like were you just like completely blown
away I think I was more relieved than
anything honestly I think I was just
like oh my god these are people that I
can have a conversation with because
that's something that is very void in in
the democratic spaces you have to agree
with everyone and if you don't agree
with them you're a horrible person and
so I had for a long time kept some of my
I've always been a centrist really I'm
not I've never been terribly far left
and I'd always kept my views to myself
whereas like these people I was having
robust conversations with them even in
line and I let it slip a couple times
you know oh I'm I'm a Democrat and they
were like oh my god welcome you were so
glad you're here and that was very
different than what I was expecting
yeah I know the feeling so then you go
and you hear Trump talk
okay there's some agree to disagree
stuff no Nazis all good you decide to
write about it
how'd that work out I did well I almost
didn't even write the article to be
honest because I was like I this is not
my lane I don't want to talk about
politics I'm gonna get in trouble I'm
gonna make someone mad whatever but then
I sat down at my desk the next day and I
just I had to get the like out of my
system and so I went on to medium cuz I
was like I don't really use medium I
hadn't published there in over a year
it's like no one's ever gonna see this
and so I wrote the whole article that
surprised I wrote it at about 20 minutes
and didn't even proofread it before I
posted it and just threw it up and kind
of posted it on a couple of like Twitter
and Facebook and all that and really
thought nothing of it after that and it
got about 200 views the first day and
then the next day it was like a bomb
went off on my life yeah so what okay so
you put it up you're not really
expecting much of anything and then you
know you just can't control the viral
nature of these things do you know where
the energy behind it started was there a
specific person that caught it that set
it on fire I still haven't been able to
figure that out honestly it started
going viral in the morning and then I
know a whole bunch of people from Fox
News tweeted it and glenn beck tweeted
it and at some point in the afternoon
Trump jr. tweeted it and that was when
it all lee started going out of hand but
I mean it just I'm I haven't been able
to pinpoint what exactly happened okay
so the thing goes viral you're getting
support from people that maybe you
traditionally wouldn't have thought
would have supported you the president
son I mean this is this is getting weird
what kind of reaction did you get and
base it why don't you just lay out a
little bit more what you said in the art
of I mean it's sort of what you've laid
out here but maybe a little more
specifically so that when we talk about
the reaction it'll be a little better
frame yeah so basically what I said in
the article was that you know we need to
start taking steps towards one another
and to start healing the political
divides and that I think was the big
message I wanted people to take away
from it is that Trump supporters are not
bad people and you know hopefully a
liberal writing this article if Trump
supporters think that you know I'm a bad
person they're gonna see that you know
someone someone has your back and I
think that that was what
Trump supporters really appreciated
about it was there was this person
coming and saying you know you're not a
Nazi I know you're not a Nazi we just
have different ideas and let's talk
about those ideas and so yeah and then
it was often running and the response
from the the Trump supporters are the
conservative community and those are not
always the same thing I've discovered
it's it's been amazing right they they
really they they embraced me and they
was as so many of them said you know I
don't agree with you on a lot of
political issues but I'm so glad you
wrote this I'm so glad you're speaking
your mind and let's have those
conversations and a lot of them too I
mean I was overwhelmed with the amount
of notes I got from people saying you
know my husband is a Republican a
Democrat I don't know how to make our
marriage survive war you know people who
have lost family members over this and
so a lot of people really appreciated
that I think they saw in me someone that
said you know it's possible to get over
your trump derangement syndrome and that
gave a lot of people hope yeah and then
you know you find yourself on the other
side of this and then suddenly all the
people that you might have thought were
bad guys are being nice to you and
agreeing to disagree and the rest of it
there there's a moment there where you
have to kind of be like oh was I was I
really wrong you have to do a little
self-reflection right yeah and I've been
actually pretty transparent since then
that I you know Trump derangement
syndrome is a real thing I had it for
years I I regret so many of the things
that I said to people over the last
couple years now that I've seen the
other side of it and can you tell me
about can you tell me some of the types
of things that you would say to people
because when you when people talk about
it as being a real thing you know it's
like it's it's sort of this knee-jerk
response that people just go to so I
think hearing you sort of say the type
of things that maybe you would have said
to somebody would be kind of interesting
yeah so I there was one person
specifically that was a trump supporter
that was always posting on my own
Facebook page like these crazy things
and I would say horrible things to this
woman because my aunt wasn't a trump
supporter and she was obviously annoyed
by it so I was trying to defend her a
little bit and I would call this woman
every name in the book I would say
anything I could that I thought might
hurt her to try to get her to stop and I
look back
on that now and I'm like oh my god like
what were you thinking because it just
skews absolutely everything the way you
see everything I thought this was
completely okay I was like she supports
Trump's I mean she's a horrible person
and she deserves to have these things
said so in that relationship
specifically I'm very regretful of many
of the things that came out of my mouth
yeah all right so now you're agreeing to
disagree with some people but I'm
guessing that you get this article out
there and it didn't just become a love
fest on all sides did it no it did not
become a love fest on all sides and
there was definitely I mean all the
blowback that you typically hear from
the left I definitely was on the
receiving end of that blowback I have
gotten more hate mail in the past two
months than I ever thought I would get
to experience in my lifetime it's been
super fun um but I mean the hamiel like
whatever the overwhelming love from the
conservative community has kind of
balanced out the hate mail but the thing
that really has been impactful in my
life is that I lost clients over this
clients that I have served well clients
that they would even say when they email
me you know you've always been great for
our team they've always loved you but we
we can't work together anymore and you
know and also my friends I mean I lost
so many friends over this I actually
came from the world of higher education
a lot of my friends were in higher
education and over time I had watched
them become pod people and didn't really
understand it and I think when this all
happened the rubber kind of met the road
and I've lost friends that I was friends
with for decades people that I was in
their weddings or people that you know
I've always been there to get on a plane
and go see them anytime they needed
anything and so that's been that's been
the most difficult piece of it yeah and
that's the part that I think people
can't really believe because you know
every few months a story like yours
bursts forth and the way I get to it is
that suddenly on Twitter everyone's like
Dave Dave there's another one it's
happening right now and then you know
it'll then you came to my attention and
it happened before you with James
d'amore brett weinstein or a plethora or
lindsay shepard a whole slew of other
people who were all lefties in some
cases academics who do one thing that
then caused them to be put in this new
position
so where does that kind of leave you now
you know I've been very blessed to have
made a lot of new friends in this
experience and the old ones I have kind
of just let go away because if they're
going to break off a friendship of years
or over a decade in some cases then
really are those people that I want in
my life anymore and you know not all
friendships or relationships are meant
to last forever maybe you can appreciate
the things that we're good but you know
the thing of it is is a lot of them -
it's they didn't even say anything to me
it was just like one day they stopped
talking to me and one day I noticed they
unfriended me on Facebook and and so if
they want to go over something so silly
then fine yeah what about the ones that
did talk to you though because I had
similar things I mean I had at least one
friend who was invited to my wedding
that you know told me I was a racist and
that was it even though you know she
couldn't point to anything racist I said
but it was enough to just say it that
it's self-evident you know I mean what
were the types of things that people
were saying to you and did you were you
ever able to walk anyone back off the
ledge because that's what I think a lot
of people are always curious about like
they're afraid that if they come out so
to speak out of the political closet
that they're gonna lose friends and they
won't know how to react when people say
all these horrible things about them
yeah so I'll start with the good news is
is the good news is that there were
people that maybe they were never like
the uber left is that that stuck around
and I was able to have conversations
with them actually just had one earlier
today with someone who was just asking
my opinion on the federal judges that
Trump reported it like appointed and all
that and we had a good conversation it
was a good dialogue and so there is hope
that some of your friends will stick
around but the other things that
happened is I have this one in
particular and I've been very
transparent about documenting what's
been going on in my experience and I
actually posted a video to my YouTube
the other day of me reading something
that one of my friends posted on my wall
and like crying and all that stuff and
it actually reminded me of something I
think I heard from you which is you had
a conversation with a friend and you
asked him do you think I believe what I
do as strongly as you believe what you
believe and he said no and it was
exactly the same
thing exactly the same thing and I was
so angry at her because she was like
you're just pandering and doing all this
stuff for the left for ego stroking and
all this I'm like no I'm really not this
is actually what I believe and I just
could never tell you what I believe
because this would happen yeah and just
that that concept though that you
wouldn't grant someone that you're
friends with the the belief that they
might believe what they purport what
they say to believe it's so profoundly
offensive it's it's really something you
know you'll find this interesting I
haven't even said this publicly before
but I have a friend who's a public
person in the political space well I
can't say as a friend a former friend
who has publicly gone after me many
times over the last couple years who
called me in the last few months to
apologize because he heard me say that
exact line that you just quoted and he
got it used against him by someone that
was further left than him and then he
thought whoa maybe I've been wrong about
Dave all these years we've been trying
to figure out how we can have a public
maiya culpa but that's the thing that I
always say it comes for everyone so the
people that are using these tactics on
you if they ever have a flicker of an
original thought it'll come from them
it'll come for them too yeah and what
I've been telling people is that the
only thing that you can really do for
people like that in your life is create
the space for them to change and create
the space for them to come around I
can't force my friends to do anything I
can't force my friends or former friends
I suppose to see me in a certain way but
someday they might have an aha moment
just like I had the aha moment and if
that happens then I'm not gonna make
them feel bad I'm not going to make them
grovel on the ground to get back in my
life I'm just gonna say I love you and I
accept you and you know I'm glad we can
move forward so are you a card-carrying
Republican now I'm not a card-carrying
Republican I did an interesting epilogue
to my articles I did actually end up
going to CPAC right after it came out
because everyone was telling me about a
week and a half afterwards anyway you
have to go you have to go you have to go
and I had a really great experience at
CPAC actually again like liberty-loving
people and I'm a fan of that but no I am
I deregistered from the Democratic Party
a couple days after my article came out
I became
independent I was very excited to do
that and I'm just gonna sit in the
middle for a while because fundamentally
my perception of both parties is that
they're like two sides of the same coin
they act exactly the same and neither of
them wants to admit it and I have you
know Democratic tendencies I have more
conservative tendencies and so I'm just
gonna sit back with my popcorn and let
them fight it out so using a little bit
of your educational training the
psychological aspect of all this have
you thought I'm sure you have about
perhaps the psychological makeup that
leads someone to be a lefty or that
leads someone to be a righty and why it
would be that right now at this moment
we're at right now why the lefties would
be so hysterical and are authoritarian
while the people on the right broadly
speaking are much more open and decent
do you have any theories behind that
yeah I think that people on the Left
agend tend to be much more focused on
emotions and how people feel and where's
people on the right or just like just
just the facts please just just the
logic and I think that that plays into a
huge role and I think a lot of people on
the left with their crazy hysteria I
think for most of them comes from a good
place of wanting to make the world
better and for people to be accepted for
exactly who they are and they don't
realize that folks on the on the right
are already much more open than they
have probably ever been to people who
look differently or speak differently or
think differently or live differently
and they don't realize that shift is
taking place and so they're doubling
down on the left because they think it's
the only way to create this more fair
just world yeah do you think the biggest
fear for the people that we're trying to
destroy you and make sure that you
couldn't maintain business relationships
and the rest is that partly what it is I
think I think at least is that they're
their ideas have become so thin that
they fear that if they let you walk if
they let me walk if they let any of this
endless amount of people walk that
everyone will walk and when I now go to
events or most of the public speaking
that I do which is I'm only invited by
conservatives and libertarians really
and I tell them what my differences are
and it's all good I see a true
diverse group of people now if maybe
because of their gender and sexuality
and skin color I don't really care about
that but there is some of that sure but
I see people debating and nobody's angry
at each other I mean that that's the
weird thing so that welcoming thing it's
like the lefties can't really let you
see that because if you see that then
well that's pretty attractive to know
you could go into a room and say what
you think and not be harrangue for it I
think that that's giving a lot of
lefties a little bit too much credit to
be honest for where a lot of them are
right now I don't do that too often well
and I think you know I mean and I had
this same experience at CPAC one of the
most surprising things to me about CPAC
was it was such a diverse audience and
some of the people there were that were
the most celebrated were people that the
left would say are in these mine or
marginalized oppressed communities and
so no I mean I really think that they
just see I mean just like I did they
perceive Republicans as being this
closed group that just wants to keep
everyone that our old white men down and
I I think that you know what's what's
fascinating is that the left can't
articulate arguments they can't even
have debates they can't just hat they
can't have discussions they don't know
why they believe what they believe and
once you start analyzing that you really
start to see that oh this isn't what I
thought it was at all so I think you're
right that if you let people analyze
these things they are going to walk yeah
so has business all worked itself out
and you're doing okay non dirt or
threatened where is the knitting
community at the moment I mean this was
the gamergate blow apart and so what's
happened I'm trying to get them shut
down and they've actually called the
police on them and now they're trying to
get their government permission
rescinded and so this is still going on
but I think what's unique about the
knitting world is that a lot of us are
now pushing back
and it actually really started with I
mean when my article that's so much
attention and they had this giant
spotlight on them so many new people
started speaking up and started posting
videos to say this is not okay
I am NOT okay yes and I actually think
that this could be a model for when this
happens in other communities for you
know if people can speak up people can
organize people can say no your mobbing
and bullying is not alright and if you
can get enough people to do that then
you can start to take their power away
yeah well I love that and I don't know
that anyone has ever been better
equipped to deal with it than a
psychologist who specializes in bullying
so you survived you made it to the other
side do you have any other you know
pieces of advice or wisdom that you
would share with anyone going through
their own version of this right now what
I would say is that the freedom that I
have discovered in being able to speak
my mind without fear it's just something
that I wouldn't trade for anything
listen like I was terrified when my
article went viral I was like this is
gonna destroy everything I'm gonna lose
my business I'm gonna lose everything
I've worked for for years but that
hasn't happened and there is some
temporary pain to go through this type
of experience however I'm so glad it
happened because now I feel like I
completely lost my filter now I can say
whatever I want and they can't come and
hurt me and so I wouldn't trade it for
the world
that is how you end an interview if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell